cette entreprise de signalétique dans le
btp a perdu près de 50% de son chiffre
d'affaires pendant le confinement mais
elle a survécu grâce à ses fonds propres
et en trouvant de nouveaux clients
ces machines ont produit des plaques de
protection en plexiglas des panneaux sur
le co vide alors à l'époque pas besoin
d'être financière aujourd'hui par
précaution elle a tout de même demandé
le prêt garanti par l'état suite à une
réunion que nous avons eue avec d'autres
experts comptables là il nous a proposé
de faire la demande
pour m voilà ce cet apport financier de
côté au cas où voilà le problème de
pandémie reviennent depuis la
réouverture des chantiers l'entreprise
d'une quinzaine de salariés repris son
activité traditionnelle pour le mois de
septembre elle a réussi à récupérer son
chiffre d'affaires de 2019 et pense même
pouvoir l'augmenter mais toutes les
petites entreprises n'ont pas eu cette
chance la région ile de france a mis en
place plusieurs z le fond relance le pm
relance mais aussi le four bon nous
avons accordé 200 millions de prêts nous
allons leur est abondée c'est la bpi la
banque publique d'investissement qui
gère les demandes de prêts et oui on en
a encore besoin les entreprises ont
encore besoin de s'endetter pour
investir à lacets pme on ne cache pas
son inquiétude de l'avenir la
confédération compte plus de 600
adhérents
c'est la grosse difficulté du moment
c'est l'incertitude c'est de pas savoir
ce que de quoi demain sera fait subir
une fermeture pendant un mois
je pense que la majorité des structures
arrive à résister à ça puisqu'on sait
contient des murs et cantine fin on y
arrive ce qui est le plus dur pour nous
c'est de pas savoir ni quand ni combien
de temps ça va durer
depuis le début de la crise cauvier près
de quarante mille entreprises et
indépendants ont été aidés par la région
ile de france